I'm studying to be a writer at the
University of the Arts Utrecht and I was
wondering which literary character do
you most identify with
or an Avid Reader and even a writer
yourself
or what type of character do you most
identify with
more of an
anti-hero or a hero
an antagonist Maybe
thank you so much
because it's always a source of lot of
comments and no as a reader
I think I love standards character
um
but I'm I'm not so sure I would identify
myself to them
if
but you never have a clear view of
yourself
and and sometimes you view yourself as a
I mean you you dream of but uh I I I'm
much more inspired
from the political point of view by
probably probably Alexander Dumas
characters and standard ones but as a
reader my favorite one was this one as
an anti-hero I would say flauber is much
more inspiring
um
is probably one of the most inspiring
one because you know even at the end he
sees a revolution happening and
realize it will not be part of it
our continent and it's part of our the
glue you mentioned
what makes it as common
this is
precisely the ability of our literature
to invent this unique way to tell
stories
with irony
and with this approach where you can
have hero and
big I mean huge Tales almost a sort of I
mean myth and we had myth in the antique
times
but the invention of the novel in
Cervantes seen as a founding father of
of this category
is exactly that with irony and some
distance with yourself
you have hero and you have anti-hero
Don Quixote is probably an anti-hero
he's a hero as well
his boss at the same time
and this is the European identity
in a lot of other continents you have
myth you have
things and so on but we invented here in
this place and we expanded and Latin
America now is absolutely wonderful
continent just to mention one or Africa
of novelists but
this is a European invention to have
this way to tell stories and build
characters that you can love cherish
admire
and mock
so this is why I mean
this is a big chance
at the end of the day
[Applause]